hey everyone we're here at gamescom 2015
day one and I'm joined by Danny who
something an interesting new game yes we
happy we have a few yesterday I saw the
trailer to Microsoft press her I was
like wow that looks interesting kind of
kooky looking 60s Britain mask-wearing
nonsense I went in to see what it was
like very interested in this game you
told me briefly about a home camera and
it seems way more complex and take
trying to handle issues that wave well
yes so there's this weird like sort of
mental health drug-taking classism thing
happening but let me just kind of step
back a little bit so the game that it
kind of reminds me of is a little bit
obscure sir you are being hunted which
came out on steam i think it was last
year to year before so it's this
randomly generated and a world where you
are you spawn and it's a roguelike in
that when you sort of you learn from
dying you can do something dumb you
learn from it and then you start to
learn the rules of the game world the
rules of the antagonists as you play so
basically the society as it is in the
game at the moment is made up of like a
couple of different little little towns
and biomes one of them is like this
really fancy kind of la-dee-da sixties
britain town where everyone's on this
drug called joy so it makes them super
happy and they all take joy and it's it
and they don't like people who aren't on
joy so you can think of it as like 9p
depressed yeah kind of summer
mind-blowing yeah fortunately staples
bring front exactly because there's also
this other town which is across a bridge
and where people aren't taking is or
they are they tried and it didn't work
so they're all bummed out so they all
got pushed out of the society because
they're massive towners and if you go
over there and you're like looking nice
in your suit or you're on joy they don't
like you because they're envious of you
so basically it's kind of like a
first-person like stealth game in which
you are trying to you're trying to go
through these different towns these
different sort of i like to call them
biomes because they're definitely
separated and there's different rules in
each one and you're basically you are a
person who has decided to stop taking
joy because if they want to be happy or
sad they'd rather feel it themselves
than benumbed to it which is very like
antidepressant kind of day and you're
basically going through the world
learning what you need to collect to get
out of the society I mean in the trailer
that they showed you know Microsoft
press conference I have loads of like
these older men hmm very happy fake fake
ice trying to inject you with something
and that drug I'm assuming it's join yes
it changes the way kind of perceive the
world right it does so like you can see
you if you attack a Barbie or you tack
somebody's you can push people away this
isn't a shooter this isn't a game you're
going upstream you could push people too
and you can fight with your fists I'm
sure you can make some weapons as well
but if you do that the bobbies because
they're basically British Bobby's a
policeman sorry in North America and
they'll still come with the fuzz there
come up and hit you got any more no
Garda will say for the Irishman and we
they come up and they start beating on
you but some of them will just be like
oh you're not on joy why aren't you on
your joy and they inject you and then
because the game is based over days and
sleep and as a cycle you basically wake
up like you just had a vendor you've
just been like whew so you wake up with
a different part of the town and like
you may have just like maybe your guns
gone because you were just like whew I
don't care which I like this way so like
going back to the gameplay when people
see trailers over
it looks closer to something like a
narrative driven shoot like Bioshock but
lucky that you alluded to it is more of
a robe like so on it like a moment to
moment basis what is why is the conceit
of gameplay how are you progressing what
you're trying to do you're right they're
kind of trying to get a best of both
worlds so while you're doing moments a
moment is you are walking around these
environments looting stuff you're going
in like for instance if you're going to
a bathroom in a medical cabinet this
chance of there being drugs there and
then you can crap that in like your your
home base little area which is based in
one of the tube station subway stations
because it's kind of like a faux Britain
for London so moments a moment what
you're doing is you're you're walking
around trying not to raise too much
attention like for instance if you stand
if we're here in the column answer and
you stood people it'd be like what the
hell are you doing if you're looking at
you just stood there but in video games
we stand there all the time we jump up
and down so if you do any of these
things or if you crack if you crouch
jump up and down or just stand there
people are like pokey doing what's going
on so you have to like acts normally
within those places so like if you're
wearing a nice suit they don't like you
because they're like you're from the
other tests you've to tear up your suit
which is perfect because like if you are
in real life the kind of person is going
through some minute we something issues
that you're trying to overcome you spend
most of your time trying to act normal
and yes hiding all that within yeah just
doing your very best to I'm putting a
finger on balance yeah exactly it's like
if won't that we've been
to the actual core game yes so there
deputy exactly so they're definitely
making like the talking about classes
and we're talking about mental health
they're talking about using using drugs
to make yourself feel better I know
that's the sort of the moment-to-moment
game players if walking around and
exploring but there's also a little bit
of narrative stuff in there as well
didn't allude to it it's early i feel
like it's early in development they said
there were nine months out and so maybe
it's actually not that already but one
of the things i also saw was that your
player character isn't somebody you make
but i think they have a couple of them
and i think those people have their own
stories to tell so once you've like
completed the game once you've gotten
out with one of the characters maybe you
could try with another one and maybe
there's some sort of different conceit I
don't know but what I felt like playing
this game was I'm really enjoying
learning head the game world works and
we enjoying how to trick the different
people in the different areas and I was
fascinated I once they each have broke
into a house right there's nobody
looking so I like break into a house I
close the window there's a lady in the
house she doesn't see me I walk around
and then I'm in the bathroom and I just
go I have some water because you also
have to survive early things you have to
eat and drink so I drinks on with the
water stoned who everything's like color
palette goes up and it's like music
playing and stuff they're great fun it's
really really come up personally I'm
really excited to see how it handles
mental health issues it's just an
interesting new direction so yeah so for
more on are we happy few and other games
at gamescom 2015 keep it gamespot
you